what if i told you that in three months
you could grow a quarter of a century
younger you'd probably think that this
sounds like some kind of late night
infomercial for desperate housewives or
old people
but that is what a recent study resulted
in see for a long time some people
thought that if you just simply replace
your blood ever so often with the pure
sterile blood of the young
you'd live longer however there hasn't
been much proof that blood transfusions
work
and it might be illegal or maybe a
little immoral
but do not fret because that is where
this new study comes to the rescue
no longer do you have to contemplate
sucking out the blood of innocent
children to rejuvenate your body
because in this study the cells of
participants aged and reversed by the
equivalent of a staggering 25 years
with something much less invasive
compared to blood transfusions
see most generally accepted ways to slow
down aging today only slows down your
body a tiny bit
so 25 years backwards is a major
milestone to say the least
and what's crazier is that the method
they use to achieve these results
isn't limited to the ultra wealthy this
modern more ethical take on blood
transfusions is pretty accessible to the
average person
and in this video we're going to break
down what happened how they did it
what this means for the future of
humanity and if you stick to the end
we'll go over how you may be able to
give yourself this very same treatment
right now for not that much money
this video was brought to you by
brilliance the best place to learn
skills in a new way that are fundamental
to feels like immortality
skills like computational biology
scientific thinking the essentials of
science with fun and challenging
interactive explorations
or maybe you're interested in other
revolutionary fields like cryptocurrency
artificial neural networks quantum
computing
whatever it is brilliant allows you to
get the foundation you need to leave
your mark on this world with their 60
plus
courses stay tuned to the end of this
video to learn more or
pause the video right now and join over
8 million people learning on brilliant
by going to brilliant.org
jake tran to sign up for free the first
200 people that go to that link will get
20
off the annual premium subscription
that's brilliant.org slash jake tran
with the link below
to understand how to cure aging we first
have to understand what causes aging
and don't worry as always on this
channel we're gonna try to explain the
science behind the stuff as simply as
possible so we can focus on the bigger
picture
aging is one of those great mysteries in
life that's up there where how
consciousness works
so there's still much debate on what
really causes aging
so this study attack was one of the more
popular theories the ends of our
chromosomes have what's called telomeres
you can think of telomeres like the
plastic ends on your shoelaces that
keeps them from fraying
basically these telomeres are structures
made up of dna and proteins that protect
our dna to make sure they get properly
copied when cells divide
when dna gets copied a tiny portion of
the ends get cut off
so some genetic information gets lost in
translation
kind of like when a copy machine cuts
off some text at the bottom of a page
this is where telomeres come in they
basically act as extra printer paper to
catch any genetic information that would
have been otherwise cut off when your
cell divides
and just like printer paper over time
your supply runs out
as cells divide more and more your
telomeres get shorter and shorter until
there's not enough left
and when your telomeres have been
exhausted that cell can't divide anymore
and it turns into a zombie
a senescent cell as the nickname implies
senescent cells stuck around don't die
and act as zombies feeding off
surrounding cells and causing harm to
your body
these zombie cells contribute to
horrible things like diabetes heart
disease and more
and the longer you're alive the more
your cells replicate the more your cells
replicate the shorter your telomeres get
the shorter your telomeres get the more
zombie senescent cells you get
which leads to more aging and you having
a higher chance of catching those
horrible health problems we just
mentioned
but it's not just time that shortens
your telomeres it can also be things
like smoking not exercising stress
etc in other words the length of your
telomeres acts as a good marker for your
biological age
how worn down your body is at the cell
level and for a long
time researchers have only been able to
slow down the shortening of your
telomeres by a very small amount via
drugs and basic things like diet and
exercise
that is what researchers at the tel aviv
university were about to change
to not just slow down the shortening of
your telomeres but to actually
regenerate telomeres to make them longer
basically they were able to make cell's
agent reverse
and were able to get rid of a lot of the
zombie cells at the same time
and the unlikely method they used to
reverse aging pressurize oxygen chambers
hyperbaric oxygen chambers are basically
where you lay inside a tube that's
pressurized with 100
oxygen it is basically like taking a
dive down to about
30 meters this combination of both
pressure and oxygen allows your blood
and lungs to fill up with more oxygen
than
otherwise would have hyperbaric oxygen
therapy has actually been around for a
while and has been used to treat a ton
of stuff
like decompression sickness for scuba
divers serious infections bubbles of air
in your blood vessels healing tissue
faster and much more
there really are a multitude of benefits
the first of which
is healing your natural tissues one of
the professors involved in the study has
been using these oxygen chambers for
years
to improve things like brain function
damage by age stroke and brain injuries
but up until now no studies have ever
tried to see if hyperbaric oxygen
therapy could help us deal with telomere
shortening or to fight off those zombie
cells
now it was time to see if these chambers
could help humanity defeat the one
enemy we've been fighting since the dawn
of time death
[Music]
so here's what they did they took 35
adults that were 64 or older
these adults didn't have any existing
cognitive decline and were in overall
decent cognitive shape
the researchers measured the patient's
telomere length and the amount of
senescent cells beforehand to get a
baseline via blood samples and these 35
subjects would then put through 60
oxygen chamber sessions over the course
of three months
at five sessions per week each session
in the chamber will set out 100
oxygen at two absolute atmospheres or
two times the air pressure at sea level
and the patient was staying there for 90
minutes with 5-minute air breaks every
20 minutes
to keep everything controlled
researchers monitored the patients to
make sure they kept their nutrition
exercise and medication the same as
before and throughout the study they
would measure the participants telomere
lengths and senescence cells at the 30th
and 60th session
and at the first and second week mark
after the sessions ended
this is what they found
each of these graphs are for the
telomere lengths for different kinds of
cells to help our bodies fight off
disease and cancer
so the bigger the bar the better and as
you can see thanks to the oxygen chamber
therapy
all the telomeres of these important
cells grew by a significant amount
with some telomeres repairing nearly 40
of its length
or in other words these telomeres age
backwards into our younger states
the same is true when researchers
measured how many of those zombie cells
remain during and after the therapy
again each graph is for different types
of helpful cells that have turned into
senescent cells
in this case the lower the bar the
better because less zombie cells
with one of them decreasing another
staggering 37
post therapy
[Music]
so what does all this mean for you well
for the first time
we've discovered that by simply putting
yourself in a glorified 2 for 90 minutes
a day
you can age a pretty important part of
your body your blood cells
backwards by the equivalent of 25 years
and after just three months of sessions
your blood cells telomeres could grow
upwards of over 20 percent
and your zombie cells could decrease by
10 to 37
and what's even better is that if you
live in or near a major city there's
probably multiple places that offer
hyperbaric oxygen therapy near you
with most estimates online being around
two hundred dollars per session
which comes up to twelve thousand
dollars if you want to do all 60
sessions just like the study did
is 12 grand a lot of money absolutely
should you do this yourself
it depends on how much money you have to
throw around if you're older you've done
well for yourself your chances of
getting diseases that comes with older
age are starting to stack up a little
higher than you're comfortable with
and you're willing to experiment with
your body well if this gives you a
chance to maybe spend a few
more days a few more months or maybe
even a few more years on this planet
you might happily pay 12 000 to enjoy
life just a little
longer not medical advice by the way
definitely not a doctor even though my
parents wanted me to be
you doctor yet but not all hope is lost
if you're not rolling in cash
nowadays you can pick up your own
personal hyperbaric chamber for around
22 000
which if you plan on doing this longer
than five to six months it might be
worthless
just keep in mind that this particular
one only goes up to 1.3 absolute
atmospheres whereas the study went up to
2.
how would that affect your results i
have no idea but
as this technology gets more attention
as more people are interested in doing
this kind of therapy
prices will go down but it's not all
sunshine and rainbows
because this discovery isn't without its
limits
the biggest limitation is that at the
end of the day the study only had 35
participants
35 participants that were all 64 and
older so we don't know if we see the
same drastic effect on younger people
we also don't know how long these
results will last or how often people
will have to keep up these sessions
but on the other hand these results are
a little too impressive to ignore
and at the end of the day the dream of
immortality is a far
off one but at least this is a step in
the right direction
immortality research is about as cutting
edge as it gets
but the thing about research and science
is let's be honest it's pretty
intimidating
but if you want to be on the cutting
edge if you want to partake in
revolutionary views like this that leave
an impact on humanity
well then that is where today's video
sponsor comes in brilliant
i myself love watching educational
videos on youtube
but you get to a point where you can
only learn so much without actively
putting your brain through the paces
it's the equivalent of learning how to
drive a car through watching videos
without actually getting behind the
wheel in a safe environment to put your
skills to the test
and brilliant allows you to do just that
their 60 plus courses are all crafted by
award-winning teachers researchers and
professionals from mit
caltech duke microsoft google and more
to allow you to have that fun
interactive environment to actively
learn things like machine learning
chemical reactions
programming with python science and
technology are moving at breakneck
speeds with plenty of humanity altering
opportunities to take advantage of
but none of that matters if you don't
have the skills so the clock is ticking
join over 8 million people learning on
brilliant by going to brilliant.org
trend to sign up for free
and the first 200 people that go to that
link will get 20 off the annual premium
subscription
that's brilliant.org jake tran the link
is on the screen and in the video
description below
if immortality is something that you're
interested in be sure to check out our
other video essay on this subject that
goes over other ways researchers around
the world are tackling the disease of
aging that are completely different from
this method
ironically this topic of immortality has
been one of the most polarizing topics
on this channel
apparently you guys are okay with
robbing banks assassinations organized
crime but living forever
it's foolish unethical it takes away all
the meaning of life
which are valid points mind you let me
know in the comments below because i do
try to read all of them and it's good
for the almighty youtube algorithm
i'm out of time right now so i didn't
have time to record a typical outro
but thank you for watching subscribe for
more video essays just like this on the
most thought provoking stuff in the
world of business
if you want behind the scenes stuff day
in the life kind of stuff memes
equally thought provoking quotes that i
come across in my reading that you're
not going to hear anywhere else
you can follow me on instagram
jaketrend.io and play your part in
helping me not be a pleb anymore by
getting me up to at least 10
000 followers stay dangerous out there
and i'll see you guys in the next one
you